[Musica]
quando penso al salto
penso a mia madre mia madre che mi
cicatrizza dopo che ho provato il salto
mortale sul letto di mia sorella quello
a castello
mia madre che mi guarda spaventata
mentre provo a saltare la staccionata di
casa al mare quella piena di cactus mia
madre che mi afferra mentre però volt
riposato col cuscino e mia madre che mi
ribadisce di non saltare perché perché
se cadi ti fai molto male a paestum
c'è una cosa meravigliosa è una
sepoltura affrescata all'interno come sa
vadano in campania un dipinto realizzato
solo per il morto sul coperchio della
della sepoltura è raffigurato un uomo
che si sta tuffando la tomba è nota
penso molto nota come tomba del
tuffatore il truffatore ha preso la
rincorsa si è lanciato ed è pronto a
cadere lì in acqua e poi e soprattutto
colto nel momento essenziale in cui lo
slancio deve ancora esaurirsi e
soprattutto il tuffatore è lì bloccato
in bilico in aria
sospeso il tuffatore poi è nudo per chi
si è spogliato di tutto quanto
appartenesse al mondo di qua ha lasciato
ogni avvenimento terreno e si è buttato
si pensa che il tuffatore era presente
il defunto e il mare l'aldilà la metà
fra quindi è piuttosto chiara
raggiungere l'aldilà come in un salto un
giorno mia madre è tornato a casa è
tornata ma quello sguardo che quasi mi
scappava aveva tagliato i capelli era
già tanto tempo ormai che lei mi dicessi
più di di saltare
io ero il suo ragazzo attento se attento
a lei anche ma era strana sorrideva però
era un sorriso che quasi debellata una
strana e anche per lei inconsapevole
descrizioni di ciò che gli stava
accadendo
quel pomeriggio lei non mi vide arrivare
ma io la vidi osservarsi allo specchio
ea un certo punto togliersi tutti i
capelli in una volta ci mise un po a
realizzare che si trattava di una
parrucca mia madre aveva un cancro al
seno
il cranio nudo di mia madre però mi fece
pensare al truffatore e fonda la sua
pelle è nudo lui entrambi pronti al
grande salto
però io ovviamente non volevo che il mio
amato si sganciasse e lei altrettanto
così per noi è nata una storia di
liberazione perché mia mamma non è mai
morta e in fin dei conti è lì sospesa
tra la vita e la morte ma come siamo
tutti voi malata ma che non vuol dir
niente perché l'altro ne siamo tutti
malati un po malati di vita o malati di
morte
anzi la sua malattia è benigna e
proficuo perché la resa molto più
leggera non solo per la perdita di molti
capelli ma perché è più leggera dentro e
più legge renzi e come persona e poi la
malattia si è contagiata anche in
famiglia papà è molto più paziente molto
più forte e molto più vicino a lei i
miei fratellini anche se poco molto più
responsabili e mia sorella si dà molto
più da fare con le faccende domestiche e
poi e poi ci sono io io provo a essere
felice però a far felici gli altri delle
volte uno scherzo una battuta in momenti
6 però è molto difficile perché è la
malattia è così voi alla fine come il
tuffatore lui prende la rincorsa si
lancia
si tuffa e poi magari non farai anche 25
al mare
il problema è di chi rimane sopra ovvero
di chi vedeva una parte del tuffatore
andare via che poi è una parte di sé di
chi deve convivere con quella mancanza
con quella speranza di riuscire a
prendere il tuffatore lì bloccato a metà
ma con la consapevolezza di non
riuscirci mai di chi è il dolore non la
ho solo provato affrontato una volta ma
di chi deve fargli compagnia di chi lo
sfiora giorno per giorno di chi vive
nell'incertezza di non sapere quando
precisamente e dove il tuffatore cadrà e
forse sono proprio io quello che è
diventato più leggero a casa io che
ormai detesto la rabbia disprezzo le
liti io che non posso soffermarmi sulle
piccolezze e che non posso esser preso
dalle sciocchezze
perché poi alla fine non è neanche più
la forza di alzare la voce con chi me la
devo prendere
di chi è la colpa io che oggi ho capito
il valore di ogni cosa il valore di ogni
istante di ogni materiale di ogni tempo
di ogni momento di ogni cosa che da un
momento all'altro potrebbe svanire come
sa anche mia mamma
oggi ho capito che tutti noi possiamo
saltare tutto tranne una cosa ovviamente
possiamo saltare
grazie alla nostra forza di volontà ma
soprattutto per un fine per una cosa o
grazie alla persona come succede a me
grazie a mia madre mia madre oggi quando
mi guarda a saltare non è più
preoccupata anzi si fida di me perché
forse i capelli di mia madre oggi sono
diventate delle mie ali grazie
[Applauso]